[Music]
I'm going to selenium the driver
architecture so first of all today we
will be going to do the setup for
selenium IDE selenium webdriver and for
that I would suggest you to go and go to
the official website at lane of selenium
go to the download section
and here in this section selenium client
and webdriver language bindings we will
find Java in Java again rather than to
the download section click on this
download it is download the latest
version of selenium that is three point
five point three okay then you click on
download it will give you a zip file as
you can see that on the left it will
give you a zip file when you unzip this
file
we'll get libraries
like this when you unzip it we had one
nine three right here and there is one
folder that is called as live if you
open it we get all the babies slightly
right here so there are total thirty
three plus one outside that is very for
libraries in total so make sure when you
download and when you unzip it there are
34 libraries and to configure it and
your own project what you need to do
so here we have created a project where
we discussed about the Java you can go
to that project
is a right-click
properties in this properties go to Java
build path
my babies and then click on add external
charts where you will add all those 34
trial is ok so this is what we have done
in case of selenium HQs we're sorry in
case of a batch of you as well and I
hope you remember how you can add
library is now in your project back to
the architecture of the leading the
driver how it looks like how it works so
hostage there is a remote web driver so
there are two type of driver drivers in
selenium one is called as the driver and
one is called as smooth web driver
web driver is the one so what is
webdriver webdriver is the one this is
used to read or I would say selenium
session or I would say gradient
webdriver session what this session here
as you know selenium is an API so we
create a session and then start
interacting with the browser and that's
how the thing happens in case of the
driver it is used to run the script on
remote systems so like you know remember
we talked about selenium grid correct we
talked about selenium grip so this if
you are using selenium grid then we will
use remove the driver which is again
used to create sessions but on remote
systems and if I talk about on our own
system if you want pre-accession then we
use selenium we're on this grip driver
now so this web driver has different
different methods as different different
glasses or I would say bro let us being
implemented by at multiple places what
we are seeing right here let's see that
from the perspective of the
documentation of selenium itself how to
get into the selenium documentation when
you open this selenium HQ you here are
Java doc okay click on this Java doc
and after clicking search for EV driver
get it webdriver here click on that it's
an interface fitting interface okay and
these are D classes which is using this
web driver interface for let's see he
methods which is present in this
interface remember I have mentioned I
have given you an example in terms of
the database for the interface here we
can declare but we cannot define so we
have done here we have declared few
methods that is called as fine by
finally means close get get models these
are the vectors you can see that all
methods and these are the classes which
are actually implementing all these all
these methods so if you are working on
Chrome driver okay then
if you are working on Chrome driver then
don't rattle but is implementing all
this if we are working on other drivers
then they are also implementing these
same methods
curavi as you mentioned do we have a
symbol driver so what the driver has
done from 3.0 it has they cut it
separately if you want HTML driver it's
not there in this now in selenium now
okay in selenium it is not there now and
you have to download it separately now
so
you see that it is completely separate
now from selenium that is this htmlunit
driver going back to the Java
documentation
going back to the driver
so in this web driver these are the
class services implementing this
inflatable and they're all the methods
of this interface are getting
implemented in these classes and one of
them is the mode web driver class as I
have mentioned okay so the driver is
where you know the verb levers and
interface and these are the classes if
you want to work on crew we initialize
you create an instance of this class if
you want to work on half of scene create
an instance of this class if you want to
execute your scripts on the remote
browsers then you don't need to execute
or you don't need to create an object of
these glasses you just create an object
of remote web driver and the settings
for Chrome Firefox and all those
browsers is different okay and that's
what it states here remote the driver
this is the glass takes a screen shot is
one of the method this is one of the
method fine violet link takes find by
name fine by tag name so sorry methods
what we have JavaScript executor is an
interface this screenshot is an
interface so they have just mentioned
the architecture here they have
mentioned that there are multiple plus
the selenium classes that is Firefox
have a class chrome grammar class Safari
driver
it'll explore driver as well in these
classes if you want to work on Firefox
and you should have a checker driver you
should install or you sorry you should
not install you should download Jayco
driver if you want to work on Chrome
then chrome primer is the class but you
will need to download chrome driver exe
separately if you want to work out
Safari driver that will happen download
separately if you want to want to come
on internet explorer then they say the
print driver separately and that's how
to actually interact with the browsers
so for that are you know just now we
have downloaded selenium my theories as
we will be working on file for
I would suggest you download one more
thing that has gone as Mozilla Jayco
driver like it's mentioned PPT as well
if you want to work on fire pose you
should have Jaco driver as well so just
click on it click on the version number
here you go with the version number go
down we will see the Downloads if you
are watching on Windows just download
the zip you will get inside and Giggsy
unzip that and place that exe somewhere
in your system
we'll be using it so first of all what
is the key architecture it seems eat the
poo is cost down emulate the user and
open-source project keep it simple and
flexible so what is the architecture it
is very simple and flexible it's an
open-source project it can help you to
emulate the user it keeps the post down
I'll go through with this what it says
by Simon Simon Stewart I hope you are
aware who is Simon Stewart creator of
the driver who have developed this the
flower Jason Hawkins team has developed
the initial level
Linamar C but C monster word has double
of these linear driver so you may take a
look at swell at then then providing
also I'll take a look from Maya so the
driver when they have that love a driver
they these are the few things which they
always wanted they wanted to take their
project open-source they wanted to keep
it simple and hexagon they keep the they
want to repeat the course slow down and
that's why they come up with the concept
of APR then creating a tool yes of
course in later user because the humans
are not going and automating the things
we are emulating from the user point of
view we are not doing anything but we
are behaving like that and we are
checking whether things are working
perfectly or not and these are the
fourth things they have in mind and
that's how they come up with this
selenium to
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos Turner DUP and get certified
click here